Is it necessary to have related literature or studies
In your research discussion
This is research tutorial
Quick answer when it comes to your results
There is really no need to have related literature
Or studies
Because you are only representing your data
Or your findings
But when it comes to your research discussion
To say that
Your research discussion is loud and beautiful
There should be
Here's how okay
So here is the research discussion
This is where you say it
And will be explained
What are the meanings of the data
Or findings you complained about
There in your results
Here you are now interpreting
Analyze
Ignore the significance of your findings
This is where you say
What are the new ones you found out
What did your research contribute
When it comes to expanding that knowledge
That topic you have chosen for your research
This is how you can enter these related studies
Or literature
When it comes to your research discussion
So first you can use him
For context about your research
So you say
What is known about this research?
What are those who don't know yet
And what is the research gab
That they haven't explore yet
Or you notice that there is a part in that topic
That other researchers haven't taught much about
And that's the one who wants to answer
Or the one your research answers
second
You can compare your research findings
Dun to the research findings of other researches
So for example both
You found out what your research says
Then you can now say supported by
Your previous researches so far
And in this way
This will increase the reliability
Or validity of your research paper
Also here
You can shighlight
In case you have new arguments obtained
Or formed
Or if there is a difference in the results you have
That's the result that others have
Then say it
Why is this so
What are the possible variables?
Or factors that affected
Why are there differences in findings
When it comes to your researches
And lastly
You can shighlight
What did your research contribute?
Dun to the body of knowledge that exists
That's your research topic
So for example
You can say
Such a researcher has a research question
That was not answered during their research
When twenty twenty
But because of this in your research findings today
Is what you think
You can give an answer
Or of possible answers
There in their research question for finally
That question can be answered
So the bottom line is
You need related literature and studies
To make a strong research discussion
So that's it
If you have any more research related questions
Feel free to drop them here
And of course
Subscribe to my Youtube channel for more research tips
Good luck